well francis haugen very good to see you
here on sky news tonight
let's start first of all with it's
almost the breaking news the the
rebranding of facebook's parent company
as meta
people saying commentators saying well
this is because you know maybe the
facebook executives mark zuckerberg
regards it as now toxified do you think
you've been part of that process do you
think you're partly the cause
well there is a there is a classic
playbook in a crisis of you want to
change the conversation and the reality
is that changing their name will not
change the issues brought up in my
disclosure or my testimony i think
there's a little bit of a meta issue
here which is facebook over and over
again has prioritized expansion and
growth versus sticking the landing on
what they already have and i am i'm
frankly shocked at a lot of the
announcements because if we had 10 000
engineers working on safety like 10 000
new engineers facebook has the money to
invest 10 000 new engineers in something
but they chose video games over genocide
i i try not to criticize people's
intentions
um i like i focus more on systems but i
find the idea that you can invest 10 000
engineers in video games over genocide
unconscionable okay i've got to pick you
up on genocide i mean that that is
incredibly strong i mean you know the
definition of jesus i mean you know how
can you back that up yeah uh well
myanmar has been established as a
genocide that was highly um
and enabled by social media in ethiopia
there are there are 100 million people
it's a large country there's an active
ethnic violence incident happening right
now that has
been accredited to facebook amplifying
it and facilitating it
this is the beginning facebook's safety
strategy like mark has written this down
you can go to 2018 read his white papers
he says engagement based ranking
prioritizing what you see based on what
will provoke a reaction
is dangerous more excited it's dangerous
because people are drawn to extreme
content but he also said don't worry we
have a.i ai will save us
and facebook's own documents say at best
they can catch 10 to 20
of the bad content
and that's only when they support the
language and that's if they invest years
more research lots of more research
right now it's only three to five
percent for hate speech
when you look at ethiopia there's six
languages
how can a strategy based on fixing each
language individually work we need to
make the platform safer we need to slow
it down when you make a human scale
because in diverse fragile places places
that are almost always linguistically
diverse facebook's current strategy will
not work
but you know what mark zuckerberg also
says about that very issue about safety
and security that uh facebook in 2021
alone spent five billion dollars
in that area that's half as much as it
is going to devote to the metaverse i
mean that is an awful lot of money
uh he he's intending to spend five
billion dollars in the next year the
usual statistic they give is that
they've invested 13 billion dollars
since 2016. so that works out to about
you know two-ish billion dollars a year
facebook in the next year is on schedule
to have a profit of like 45 billion
dollars 50 billion dollars right i think
this question is not should we have a
social media or should we not have
social media the question is
should facebook be making me 50 billion
dollars a year when
at least a billion billion and a half of
its users basically don't have any
safety systems
they also say that that is more than any
other tech company that amount of money
facebook invests far far more than its
competitors facebook uh i think this is
something most people are not aware of
facebook has subsidized the internet in
the in a large number of countries in
the world
um over a billion of their users have
come in through having facebook pay for
their internet but only if they use
facebook so facebook has bought their
way into being the internet of some of
the most fragile places in the world and
especially like uh stolen all the light
for a free internet to grow
facebook should have to spend the most
of its competitors because it is the
internet for the vast majority of
languages in the world let's talk about
uh what you've been saying about the
harms that facebook and its outlets
caused to in particular young people now
while you were giving evidence testimony
to mps here in london there was there
were demonstrators outside i'm sure
you're aware um
they had an art installation it was mark
zuckerberg
surfing over loads of money and
with saying it's a hydrofoil yeah
that's insane uh i know we harm kids but
i don't care is that a populist way of
summing up your charge against facebook
i cannot see into the hearts of men like
i i i have faith that mark is a kind
conscientious person i think it's more a
question of facebook's culture rewards
expansion and growth like their current
pivot into video games when like they're
not investing enough in safety they care
more about growing and expanding and
focusing on the positive and that's just
a cultural problem and so i don't think
it's a thing of he doesn't care it's
that he sees the good he's doing and
allows him to ignore the bad that's very
interesting
just tell me about your motivation then
you talk there about mark zuckerberg
what about you francis hogan um you're
taking on
one of the most powerful companies in
the history of the planet no doubt
there's some personal cost um to you but
you know what motivated you to take that
step
i think very reasonable people can look
at a situation where their actions would
save a life and say i'm not willing to
accept those costs right like that's not
my that's not the burden that i want to
take on but if the number of lives you
thought you could say was 10 or 100 or a
thousand i think that would change a lot
of people's calculus
i am an algorithmic specialist i have
seen how misinformation is spreading in
the vast majority of the world and how
it divides and polarizes us
and i earnestly believe that there might
be a million or 10 million lives on the
line in the next 20 years and there is
almost nothing i can imagine that could
happen to me that is more important or
like worse than having that many people
come to harm
you personalized that didn't you i know
while you've been in the united kingdom
you met molly russell's
father i mean she's a 14 year old girl
who committed suicide her family say
because of some of the material that was
posted about her on on instagram is that
your justification for doing this
i was originally motivated more by the
global south that i i feel like the
ethnic violence we're seeing right now
in ethiopia is just the the first
chapter the second chapter myanmar is
really the first chapter in a novel that
is going to be horrific
but
here at home things like molly russell
are about the suffering of children
engagement based ranking the way
facebook you know prioritizes that
content basically scans you and says
what are you most vulnerable to what
rabbit hole can we pull you down and for
a child who might be getting bullied a
child who might be experiencing doubts
about themselves as they mature
that can lead very rapidly to self-harm
content to eating disorder content
because it's so attractive it's
addictive
and there's some uh
so troubling troubling it's not the
right word it's stronger than that
statistics aren't there 32 percent of
girls
said that they felt worse about
themselves um after being on instagram
13.5 percent of uh british teens said
they had suicidal thoughts they were
they were more frequent after some of
the material that they'd been accessing
is that another reason why
certainly like facebook's own studies
have shown that you can take a brand new
account it has no friends it has no
interests and follow very mild interests
like healthy eating
and because these algorithms amplify and
suck you down rabbit holes just by
clicking on the content facebook
presents to you you will get led to
anorexia content rapidly and that's
because these algorithms it's not bad
content or bad people it's the
algorithms in the system that amplify
these interests is dangerous but the
worst thing that you're asserting
because you've worked on the inside is
these things are happening but that
facebook knows about it knows about the
harms that are being caused and makes a
judgment
makes a judgment that we will continue
to to monetize this kind of content
rather than remove it
facebook is a deep believer in flatness
right like social media is flat facebook
has the largest open floor plan office
in the world it's a quarter of a mile
long one room
5 000 people
worked before covid
they don't want to acknowledge that they
have power like it's foreign to them
they believe everything is flat everyone
is equal they don't acknowledge that
they have power and because they won't
acknowledge that they can't acknowledge
responsibility and i think it's much
easier for them to divert their eyes and
focus on the good they cause then be
able to like have that awakening and
then reckoning that they are responsible
for these harms how do you answer i mean
it is a charge made against you you've
been talking to lawmakers in the united
states in the united kingdom to
politicians and it's your own
constitution the first amendment about
freedom of speech and saying well this
is a modern version of that allowing
people to communicate directly to each
other and politicians always like to
intervene in control way back hundreds
of years ago when newspapers first
started they they started taxing them to
prevent people being able to communicate
with each other one television game
along they put in rules and regulations
to control that now we've got the 21st
century version of that you are enabling
politicians who want to stop people
organizing and talking amongst
themselves
so one of the greatest
mischaracterizations of me online is
that i am like a dark horse for
censorship
so like i talked about earlier about the
idea that the world is very
linguistically diverse the fraudulent
places are linguistically diverse they
speak different languages in singular
societies
i am strongly against us having systems
that pick good and bad ideas because
they do not scale and they do not work
the thing i'm actually advocating for is
less control over what people say but
systems that are safer so i'll give an
example twitter requires you to click on
a link before you re-share it have you
been oppressed by having to click on
that link before you share it i don't
think so or like
re-share chains
let's imagine alice writes something bob
re shares it carol re-shares it and
lands in dan's news feed if he had to
copy and paste it to reshare it has he
been oppressed no but that has the same
impact as the entire third party fact
checking program
safer design choices is the solution not
picking good and bad content and
facebook doesn't want to give up the
growth and profits it gets from these
choices so if facebook doesn't do that
it doesn't do it well if it doesn't do
that then does it need either to be
broken up and or have an oversight board
an independent oversight board to to
make it do those things
i think we need regulation from places
like the uk
because facebook right now has no
incentive
to actually do accurate risk assessments
right like i i i'm concerned that
because of this disclosure they're going
to not stop asking but you should be on
those oversight
you know that that is the worry that
people get to decide then what other
people can share amongst themselves well
i think concepts of risk assessments are
if you say you need to articulate the
risks so people can choose whether or
not to use your products because right
now you're saying you do things that you
don't do right you say you support 50
languages but most those languages don't
have most the safety systems um
we need to have you you should have to
articulate what you actually are
and you should have to yourself come up
with solutions and you have to let the
public know all those things because
right now like people don't know what
the problems are and they don't know the
facebook's not working on them and so i
think systems like that are flexible
they're not about choosing good and bad
ideas but they're making sure that
facebook is engaging in a responsible
and transparent way with the public and
i know people will want to know this um
it's the obvious question but i'm
interested in it too how can are you
still on any of the facebook platforms
are you on facebook
you use what's up i am uh i i actually
really love facebook i love social media
like i've worked at four social media
companies you have to understand um i
want safe social media and i think we
can have social media that's safe that
we enjoy but it has to be human scale um
right now i have a facebook account but
i'm scared to post on it because i think
they're gonna delete it
like i'm worried that if i put more
content on it they're gonna just because
they've taken it away from other
researchers before and so i assume when
the media comes down they're going to
delete my account but we'll see but i do
have an instagram account and
we're using that because we want to give
people a little peek into the process of
reform and so twitter will be about our
ideas
and uh instagram is going to be about
like letting you see a little peek into
what's going on and just finally let's
come full circle then on the metaverse i
mean you know you kicked off this
interview by
accusing um facebook of enabling
genocide in some countries in the world
what do you think then about the the
ambition here to move into this this
metaverse as they describe it artificial
intelligence factual reality to own that
future
i am i am frankly shocked about this
announcement because i think people
aren't aware of this and this is a
really important thing to help get out
there in order to make the metaverse
happen
we have to put facebook's microphones
and their sensors in our homes in our
offices like you're gonna walk into an
office building and it's gonna be full
of facebook sensors listening to you
facebook has demonstrated over and over
again that they are not transparent they
don't tell us what they actually do and
when we ask them they actively lie to us
why would we want their microphones and
sensors in our homes
it's crazy but you know i embrace
ambition i wish him the best of luck and
i hope he's responsible with it
francis sagan thank you very much indeed
yeah
thank you so much
well a fascinating interview and in
response to those remarks made by
francis haugen about facebook's role in
myanmar and ethiopia meta the new parent
company of facebook gave us the
following statement in the last two
years we've hired more people with
language country and topic expertise
we've also increased the number of team
members with work experience in myanmar
and ethiopia to include former
humanitarian aid workers crisis
responders and policy specialists and
we've hired more people who can review
content in america oromo tigrinya somali
and burmese adding more language
expertise has been a key focus area for
us this year alone we've hired content
reviewers in 12 new languages facebook's
approach in myanmar today is
fundamentally different from what it was
in 2017 and allegations that we have not
invested in safety and security in the
country are wrong we conducted human
rights due diligence to understand and
address the risks in myanmar built a
dedicated team of burmese speakers
banned the tatmador and used technology
to reduce the prevalence of violating
content in myanmar including proactively
detecting
99 of the hate speech we remove before
it's reported to us